foreign
[Music]
the dark Caverns deep below Hyrule
Castle Link and Zelda stumble upon the
mummified remains of an ancient evil The
Demon King Ganondorf who tormented the
kingdom of Hyrule in an age long
forgotten after snapping out of his
age-long slumber quite literally The
Demon King wastes no time before even
uttering a single word he goes on the
offensive launching a double volley of
bright red malice aimed straight at the
protagonist the first attack cripples
Link's arm and steals his vitality and
the second takes out the legendary
Master Sword shattering it into pieces
at the conclusion of the encounter The
Demon King conjures up a third blast of
miasma this time aimed straight at the
ceiling after which the underground
chamber starts to crumble Ganondorf
disappears into the void below leaving
Link and Zelda to deal with the dangers
of the collapse meanwhile unbeknownst to
Our Heroes below ground a much bigger
event is taking place on the surface
above Hyrule Castle starts to fall apart
its upper levels are ripped from the
Castle's foundation and start to rise
into the air as the camera pans out
another anomaly is seen taking place
mysterious chunks of debris big and
small emerge from the clouds trailed by
a green energy the Exotic debris falls
from the sky and crashes into the
surface of Hyrule as eyewitnesses look
on in fear confusion and disbelief and
event and which would become known as
the upheaval but what exactly is the
upheaval and perhaps more importantly
what caused it the easy answer would
obviously be Ganondorf right I mean even
the newspaper claims that the demon king
is the root cause of the upheaval but we
can't just put our trust in the
mainstream media now can we I mean look
at them they're still searching for
Princess Zelda despite the fact that
everyone and their mother knows she's a
dragon by this point still the way the
game presents the event does make it
seem like it was all orchestrated by
Ganondorf in some way in fact the
upheaval parallels a similar incident
that took place not too long ago the
great Calamity an event so devastating
it almost wiped out everything and
everyone in Hyrule the similarities
between the Calamity and the upheaval
are evident both incidents started at
Hyrule Castle both are connected to
Ganondorf and his malice they were
prophesized in ancient writings and each
had far-reaching consequences which
affected most of the Kingdom's populace
but when you dig a bit deeper into the
upheaval you'll start to notice that not
everything is as it seems the calamity
he was pretty straightforward Hyrule
knew it was coming took the necessary
steps to prepare for it and Gannon using
his own knowledge of the past launched a
counter-attack by corrupting their
technology and turning it against his
adversaries with the upheaval it's a
different story over the course of the
game many different causes and effects
are attributed to the upheaval therefore
it cannot be viewed as simply one single
event but rather a collection of many
different events taking place at the
same time some that benefit Ganondorf
While others seem to actively work
against him as you'll see over the
course of this video there's evidence
that suggests that some of the stuff
that happened during the upheaval was
planned by someone a long time ago
someone other than Ganondorf which if
true could give us a bit more insight
into some of the history following
ganondorf's imprisonment so join me as
we take a deep dive into the secrets of
the upheaval
foreign
let's start with a good old-fashioned
definition in English upheaval can mean
two things a violent or sudden change or
disruption or an upward displacement of
a part of the Earth's crust both
meanings are definitely fitting though
the second one is a bit more specific
and doesn't cover the full scope of the
event after all it's not just the Earth
that's affected but other factors as
well like the sky for example in
Japanese the word used for the upheaval
translates to natural disaster or
cataclysm while I do think the word
upheaval was a clever Choice by the
localization team due to its double
meaning the second definition regarding
the displacement of the Earth's crust is
not applicable to the lore behind the
event not just because of the Japanese
version but you can also tell from the
English text that upheaval is simply
being used as a synonym for the word
disaster for example when talking to the
Rito about the legend of the Stormwind
Arc they mention a different kind of
upheaval that struck their people long
ago a time when the wind stopped blowing
and the heavens grew lifeless with that
said let's get into the details behind
the latest upheaval taking place in
Hyrule as mentioned before there are
definitely aspects to it that are
unmistakably ganondorf's doing the rise
of monster activity and the emergence of
new Monster types for example or the
sudden decay of Swords Spears and other
weapons used for offense eyewitnesses
described that during the upheaval
tendrils of Gloom spread across Hyrule
and latched onto their weapons making
them Decay rapidly aside from being a
convenient plot device for the fuse
mechanic it does make sense that
Ganondorf would want to disarm the
people of Hyrule it's made clear that
the Demon King while in his mummified
form is in a weakened State and spends
most of the game hiding deep below the
surface Gathering a strength as such
crippling hyrule's offensive
capabilities prior to his true comeback
is a good strategy then there's the four
Regional phenomena and I think it's safe
to say that Ganondorf is behind all of
them the storm in hebra the pollution of
Zora's domain the sandstorming Gerudo
and the trafficking of Narcotics in
Goron City are all connected to him be
it through Phantom Zelda or the four
bosses who guard one of the secret
Stones Ganondorf admits that he created
or at the very least resurrected these
monstrosities to do his bidding made
more obvious by the explosion of Gloom
when they perish but then there's all
the other more suspicious effects of the
upheaval many of which don't seem to
work to ganondorf's Advantage at all to
illustrate what I mean let's take the
Stormwind Arc as an example we know this
ship has existed for a long time long
before Ganondorf ever came into the
picture so it's not like he created it I
think we can all agree that it would
make very little sense that Ganondorf
would want this vessel to appear after
all it Clues the protagonist in on the
location of one of the secret stones and
yet it conveniently shows up right after
the upheaval for ganondorf's sake it
would have been far better if the ark
remained hidden I mean the Rito
themselves had long since written off
its existence as nothing more than a
children's story now if ganondorf's goal
was to obtain all seven stones and
become immortal or something it would
have been a different story but the
stones don't seem to work that way as
far as we know right now the lore
establishes that an individual can only
possess a single Stone they cannot be
sought out and combined like the
Infinity Stones or the dragon balls so
logically speaking the only thing
Ganondorf can really do in this
situation is to obscure and obstruct in
order to prevent others from obtaining
the stones before he is fully recovered
and you'll notice that that's kind of a
running theme in tears of the Kingdom
things conveniently appear or become
accessible which contain vital resources
or information regarding the history of
the Demon King the sages or the location
of a secret Stone while Ganondorf tries
to prevent link and his friends from
getting to it this applies to almost
every major effect of the upheaval while
the chasms may look like they are
ganon's doing given all the Gloom on the
flip side they also give the
protagonists access to a wealth of
information Zona technology and most
important the location of two of the
seven secret stones in one instance
Ganondorf goes out of his way to plug up
the chasm inside death Mountain's crater
seemingly to prevent link and unobo from
accessing the lost city of gorandia and
obtaining the secret stone that resides
there many of the caves that opened up
due to the upheaval just so happen to
contain shrines which allow link to
purify his afflicted arm and against
vitality and there's so much more the
appearance of the sky islands zonai
structures on the surface that rose up
from the ground and perhaps most
mysterious the hieroglyphs that
magically showed up all across Hyrule
which not only reveal what happened to
Zelda but also show ganondorf's ability
to take on her appearance which is
obviously not something he would want
people in the present to know about all
of these anomalies are confirmed to have
taken place during or as a result of the
upheaval a chain of events that was
seemingly planned ahead another great
example are the ring ruins who crashed
in and around kakariko Village if not
for these ancient monuments the
existence of the fifth Sage would have
been lost a time yet here they are
conveniently up for grabs and once again
we see the same pattern of Ganondorf
trying to obstruct one of the puzzle
pieces this time by tricking the
researchers to stay away from it if
anything it shows that the sky debris
crashing into Hyrule was not his
intention and so he improvised the
emergence of the sky islands also has no
direct benefits for the Demon King nor
do they seem to be part of his end goal
as for the hieroglyphs the Ancients knew
about their existence and even went as
far as to map them out for future
reference the map shows that Hyrule
Castle had already been built by this
point which must have happened sometime
after ganondorf's imprisonment after all
the purpose of the castle was to seal
off the underworld and with it the
imprisoning chamber where the Demon
King's corpse was being kept speaking of
which let's move on to the next and
probably most iconic part of the
upheaval the rise of Hyrule Castle this
is where for me at least the first signs
of something bigger started to emerge
because when you think about it the
castle rising up has little to no
bearing on ganondorf's plans either heck
the castle barely even serves a function
in the story at all in breath of the
wild Ganon turned it into a heavily
guarded base of operations but in tears
not so much the only significant thing
that happens after it takes to the sky
is Phantom Zelda trying to bait link
into the sanctum for a fight to the
death but the castle didn't need to rise
into the air for that if anything it
made it more difficult for link to
access the sanctum then there's the
massive pillar that protrudes from the
underworld as we all know by now the
castle isn't actually floating as many
of us initially thought it's resting on
a big Central column the column itself
isn't just natural rock either and
instead has man-made features to it
there's Engravings on it which are zonai
in origin It suggests that this pillar
is part of a mechanism that was
deliberately built into Hyrule Castle
back when it was first constructed for
what reason we don't know for sure I
mean sure the castle Rising could just
be a show of dominance by Ganondorf and
nothing more a way to crush the hylian's
morale by attacking their most iconic
landmark or something but I don't know
in terms of motivations it just doesn't
fit very well first of all the castle is
in the exact same state as it was in the
previous title that is to say completely
trashed aside from a few temporary guard
posts on the bottom levels it hasn't
been touched since which shows that it
wasn't being used for anything and
apparently restoring it wasn't exactly
high on the priority list just like the
other chasms the castles rise also has a
flip side to it when it comes to
ganondorf's goals and motivations it
actually exposes his underground hideout
making him more vulnerable to a counter
attack while he's still healing I really
failed to see what Ganondorf has to gain
from all of this which brings us to the
final segment how exactly was the
upheaval triggered in the first place
what is it that set the whole thing in
Motion in order to find out we need to
go back to where it all started deep
underground inside the imprisoning
chamber and this is where things start
to get interesting
the rise of Hyrule Castle as well as the
Falling Sky debris didn't start until
Ganondorf hit the ceiling of the cave
with his malice more specifically this
part of the ceiling which has the shape
of an upside down pyramid judging from
the position on the map this pyramid is
situated right below the massive column
that pushed the castle up into the air
if you revisit the chamber after the
opening segment it's no longer there and
seems to have moved up into the ceiling
which leads me to believe that the
column and pyramid are physically
connected to each other as mentioned
before the column has Engravings on it
that correspond to the zonai we see
similar patterns all over the place like
in raru's throne room for example the
same goes for the spiers that protrude
from the walls of the imprisoning
chamber as well as on the upside down
pyramid however unlike the column
inspires the pyramid has a secondary
decoration on it one that seems to have
been placed on top of the original zonai
Engravings in game these are difficult
to see because of the lighting and The
Limited camera angles plus the fact that
it's no longer there after the intro
making further investigation impossible
however thanks to a Discord user called
Magic pixie dream girl I've been able to
get a hold of the raw 3D model from The
Game's files and here the decorations
can be seen clear as day they are
constellations and if you're familiar
with the lore of breath of the wild they
will no doubt look familiar they're
almost identical to the constellation
seen on the shika technology I've
searched high and low and to my
knowledge there's only two pieces of
zonai architecture in the entire game
that feature constellations the other
being the inside of those big floating
spheres up in the sky however these
constellations look quite different from
the ones inside the imprisoning chamber
they've been carved into the stonework
as opposed to being placed on top of it
and their overall art style also differs
not to mention their presence here makes
more sense when put into context with
the inside of the sphere as a whole it
simulates a day and night cycle with the
sun and clouds on one side and the moon
and stars on the other the fact that we
find constellations inside the
imprisoning chamber which are so similar
to the ones the ancient chica use can be
a coin incidents especially considering
that there's a giant chica made Astro
Observatory right at the heart of the
castle or at least there used to be I
don't know if it's still there now
another interesting aspect is the name
of this model which reads field object
opening field purification unit a01 so
according to the game's files it's a
purification unit which is quite
fascinating for a variety of reasons
many of which are for another time we do
have somewhat of an idea of when this
purification unit was created which must
have been shortly after the imprisoning
war around the same time the
construction of Hyrule Castle started
because when we look at the end of the
memory where Ganondorf is sealed by raru
you'll notice a few differences between
the imprisoning chamber in the past and
the one in the present for starters the
bodies of rauru and Ganondorf have been
moved from the edge of the platform to
the center and secondly the purification
unit is not there yet it's just a rock
ceiling the only things that already
exist in the past are the platform and
those protruding spikes on the wall so
here's what I think I think that's some
of the islands in the sky and zonai
architecture on the surface may have
been directly connected to the
purification unit which is actually very
similar to how the sheika went about it
in both creating a champion and age of
Calamity there's mention of a central
control unit that exists somewhere deep
inside Hyrule Castle which is said to
control and connect many of the shika
technology most notably the towers a bit
like an electric grid I guess heck maybe
this elusive central control unit and
the purification unit are one and the
same who knows either way I suspect that
the purification unit was programmed so
that when it gets hit with a high amount
of force it would trigger many of the
events we saw happening during the
upheaval most notably the stuff related
to Zona structures like the Falling Sky
debris and certain buildings that
weren't there in breath of the wild and
allegedly rose up from the earth and
believe it or not there's actual
evidence that supports this if you
remember at the center of the
imprisoning chamber there's a circular
platform the one where ganondorf's
corpse was resting on the moment the
purification unit was hit by malice the
platform fell down into the depths below
which is something I found rather odd
the first time I saw it there's no
debris hitting it so why would it
collapse it felt very video gamey at the
time turns out it's not just a regular
Stone platform it's actually a floating
island once again this is very hard to
see in game not just because of the
darkness and fog but the game triggers a
story event the moment you try to
venture too far from the entrance and
once you click OK it's all cutscenes
from there but thanks to another bit of
help this time from the noon I was able
to view the platform in blender in all
its glory and lo and behold there's a
Spire or antenna at the bottom of it
very similar to the ones found on the
floating islands up in the sky whatever
was holding this platform up must have
been based on the same magic or
technology that keeps the sky islands
afloat the antenna and platform can
later be found at the bottom of the
chasm shattered into pieces and because
of its broken State and the Gloom
covering it it was hard to determine its
original shape but now we know the
debris itself also reveals that the
inside of the antenna is not made of
stone but rather some sort of green
Crystal and you might recognize it from
somewhere else it's the same crystal
that makes up those floating zonai
platforms link and use these platforms
usually need an external power source in
order to stay afloat in this case it's
the battery link carries on his hip that
makes it possible but some of the
islands presumably the ones that crash
down as well as the platform inside the
imprisoning chamber must have been
drawing their power from somewhere else
which I think was the purification unit
zonai technology is shown to be
activated and deactivated by applying
Force to it be it a hit from a weapon or
an arrow or something like that so what
if the sheer force of ganon's malice
hitting the purification unit basically
achieved the same thing except on a
bigger scale it would explain perfectly
why not only the chamber started to
crumble but also why debris started
raining down from the sky immediately
after if true it means that at least
some of the sky islands like the ring
ruins and zonai structures like the
entrance at tobios Hollow Were Somehow
directly connected to the unit inside
the imprisoning chamber and I can't help
but think that this was definitely done
on purpose this summarize I think that
Ganondorf was not the one pulling the
strings behind the upheaval newspapers
be damned he was at most the Catalyst
that set the whole thing in motion
intentionally or unintentionally the
purification unit and castle on top were
built after he was imprisoned so I doubt
he knew how it worked or what the exact
consequences would be my guess is that
he acted out of pure rage and impulse to
break free from the underground tomb he
was condemned to for so long even though
the exit is right there but you know how
villains are they tend to break through
walls and ceilings for dramatic effect
using a door just doesn't cut it the
question remains who set the whole thing
up this way because we have to remember
that the zonai themselves were all gone
by the time the construction of Hyrule
Castle began raru is dead and mineru
went into hibernation inside the Pura
pad right before Zelda's draconification
someone else must have picked up the
torch somehow be it the remaining sages
the ancient hylians who survived the
imprisoning war or judging by some of
the evidence perhaps this is where the
first of the Shiga came into play there
are a lot of parallels between the zonai
and the sheikah too many to just be a
coincidence however that's a topic
that's way too big to cover in this
video so instead I will devote a
separate video to the zonaishika
connection it's basically going to be a
sort of part two to today's Theory so
hopefully you will join me again for
that one a big shout out to Magic pixie
dream girl and banoon for their
contributions to this topic without them
it wouldn't have been possible and as
always a big thanks to my patreons and
channel members I'm happy to report that
I've made a full recovery no more pain
no more discomfort so I'm ready to rock
and roll once again so thank you to each
and every one of you for sticking with
me despite my silence and that is all
for now I hope to see you next time and
have a good one
[Music]
thank you